>>> WEOM "INSIDE POLITICS
LL
LEGITIMATE POLITICAL DCOS HOW T
NATIONAL COMMIEE
THIS IS NEW VIDEO RELEASED OVER
THE WEEKEND OF THAT CAPITOL
DISCOURSE.AT PHRASE WAPART OF TH
CETION AND ADAINGER.
COTHE RE THE TWO REPUBLICANS ON
AND TED ATTEMPTS
TO ON THE 20S  FORME
AK WIT
EX-BOSS, REJECTING TRUMPLA
THD HAVE AND SHOULD
HAVE OVERTURD .
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRONG.
TION. NO RTURN THE
E PRESIDENCYELTHE
AMER PE E AMERICLO TA
MORE UN-AMERICANN
AN PRESIDENT.LD CHOOSE
>>G AFTEEAR HAS PASSEDAND
ANYTHING TO DISPUTUMP'LSCL FRAU.
H THEIR
INN
MEREDI LOPEZ,
CNN'
SO LAURAT
OF DAYS ICANSCBIISNC CIRCULA
FIRINGQUADAVLLSAYING, TRUMP S WT
>> BLI
REPUBLICANS THRENG TO
S IN THE PARTY THAT ARE WILLING.
SAYING "NO" TO T HALF ISYEHETO
WHICH WANO,
HAD THIS.
YOT HE
WOULD  S DAY
OF.OM, I  T WE ARE SEEING THE
ING TO OPERATE ASYMMEALNGS PARTA
THAT THEY ARE IN
ANEMUSE THEY ARE
IN PURSU OPOWER.
AND SOS WHATHEY
OF REPUBLICANSRE.
AND EVERYTHING HAS
ALL ALONE OMTHE
T TRUMWALV HE EDVOTING MACHINES
N JUST THE -
MEAN, THE BAD ENOUGH
RIGHT?
HE CORCTSTATEMENT, SAYING TH SN
VIOLENCE,BO TO THROW
BUT HELP U
HERE.U'VE GOT MIKE NC
HE SAID WHAT HIDINK THE BAR IS
>> MARK OR, HE'S LOSING
E
HE IS LOSING INFLUENCE
IT IS HAPPIN
" HE MEANS T
IS HE >> IT'O SAY THATRU
IS LOSING INFLUENCE WHEN HE
CONTINUES TO HAVE SUCH
INCREDIBLE POWER OVER THTHAT WA
STARK AND VIVID DISPLAY ON
ID. SAWNC CINGER AND, THATAS T
WILLING TOUMP NTS.
AND HE TO BE
FOR BEING INVOLVED IN
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
AND OBVIOUSLY WITH SAYING REONG-
>> WHAT IS PENCE HAVING
ABOUT, RIGHTBATE IS ACTUAL
NOT THE 2020 ELECTIOWALEGITIMATS
STOLEN, ATWAY THAT
HE WAS STEPPININCOULN ME
WE SHOULDN'T EVEN BE TALKING
ALL TH.HE, BAN
REHAT. FULLY STEPPING OURE SOMEH
TERMS OF THE MAITHE
RETYND
ARGUMENT, THATS VERY
MUCH HNING AND ALIVE.K ITE P DI
S I THINK HE MIGHT
HA TO DO WITP
ANHE
NT PUT OUT
THISTEMENT, NEED
ITT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT ISNGN
AYS, I JUSMIKE PENCE'STE
O HING WITH RESPECT HETHANBELTR
PSI
QUICKLY.WAS RIG
OW NOT TS
T THAT STATEMENT MADE RELYVERY N
Mc.
TRUMP IS PULNG THE STRINGS ON FS
AN McDANIEL, TCHAIRWOMAN, HAS BT
TRUMP WING AND,
I DON'T INUBTHAT.
N, STAY IN THE TRU WND HER R
UT SLY IS A RELATIVE.
DE
>> EVERY TIME FORM PRESIDENTTRU.
ONLD C
ANSEY GRAHAMUSUAL ALLY SAID, MAH
RINO, WHAT MEAN?AN IN NAME ONLY.
DONALD TRUMP W MEANS TO BE A RUL
OR TO BE COMPLETELY AND
TRADITIONAL CONSERVA
KEAS ABLE E,AUSE HTY -IF H THE
MEETING, HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
'SVEIO
REPUBLICANISM IS
GH THAT'S WHAT.ERY --BOCTELECTI
STOLEN, THS NEGEART IALLL THE 2
THAT'S WHAT TH REPUBLICAPARTY I.
COMPARED T TALKINGT THE FAE DEM.
>> THERE IS NO ALTERTIENDA FOR
ELECTION.
AND TH
FRUSTRATING TO A LOT OF T JENNGS
TOCH McCONEA CERTAIN KIND OF
REPUBLICAN.
THE S INOW.
>>SOE
IT IS CU
THE CAPITOL,
DEFILE THE T -- BACK THEE. N LE
RS
AROUND EVERY CDAK
FOR THE NEYCLES.
>> THIS IS AAND DO YOU BELIEOU A
LLS DAMAGE RLLY
HANG OVETHR NEXTS?>> IA FEW SENT
THEVENT THERE INH THIS
EKRE VER
WERE ALL FOCUSED ON TRUMP AND
THE CENSORSHIP OF CHENEY AND ATR
AT THEY ARE AT
A POLIL ADVANTAGE WHT
COMEKING ABOUT THEID
ADY,
OF COVIEAD OFUS GS
KENING M
ON.D, WHAK AND WHATONTINUESO
CO OUT O MANY REPUBLICAN
TSS A FOCUS  2020, ZMOT A FOCUS
THE FUTURE OR WHAT THEIRESSAGE
MIGHT BE.
AND THIS IS WHAT HPENS WHEN
YOU HAVE A PARTY THAT'S BEIN
DRIVEN BY FEAR,
P UL DO,T --
>> AUDIENCOF ONE.
>> AND TT WHAPPEN NE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, AS IT RELES
HAD THSE OFFICIALS
AND SENIOR OFFICIALSK IN
2020, WHEN TRUMP WAS
PUSHING THESE FRAUD CLAIMS, RANA
GOING TO MICHIGAN
GS LIKE, WHY TH
ARE YOU DOING THIS?ND THAT THISO